surprise your together and dress like a
bride and groom tonight was this
intentional completely unintentional I
don't know I don't know what happened I
was just trying to look pretty up here
maybe a little subconscious and perfect
I mean you're in love with this woman is
what it is baby day yeah
do you think our story is a beautiful
one I think it is you guys seem super
happy um what was the key for you
Taoiseach to know I want to go after
this guy and get him back in my life
honestly every time I thought about
paradise or I spoke about paradise to my
family or my friends I honestly could
not stop smiling and grinning ear-to-ear
because this guy and so at that point I
was just like you know we have something
really special that doesn't happen all
the time
it happen all the time and I just I
wanted to give it a chance on our terms
[Music]
what was it like for you to head home
after things ended that were you
heartbroken yeah definitely in Paradise
was just the most emotionally traumatic
experience I've ever been through that
just kind of compounded everything and I
just try to throw myself back into work
and get over it as quickly as possible
but the shoe to see as soon as she
walked in my front door you know the
chemistry just kind of rekindled things
and we just went from there no questions
from you no hard feelings you know I get
it I mean she has every right to feel
the way she felt at the time and you
know I think I think what she did was
the most mature thing to do so so you're
in love with her absolutely where are
you at you know what I'm taking things
you know day by day and I think we'll
get there but until then I'm just happy
with them right now like he'll just take
you at because like yes I'm dating her
whatever yeah
okay notice what it is you know yeah
tastes were my wife I'd be the happiest
man tisha Paul Jones you had talked on
the show about seeing this woman as
potentially the mother of your children
one day I mean do you still feel like
you could be on that road one day when
she was ready if that happened I think
it's definitely possible for sure what
is next for you guys are you doing long
distance cuz you're in California you're
on the East Coast a lot of FaceTime
FaceTime every day and I think I think
we've sort of agreed to try to see each
other twice a month the iPhone is our
best friend Bob for the iPhone and we
saw you go and visit John Paul Jones how
long after filming ended was that visit
um it was a good a few weeks after like
three weeks this is a quick turnaround
on that day we saw you cry on the beach
did you cry over this lady when you went
home I did I did there were a few nights
of weeping for sure uh-huh
stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]